VOICEOVER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So today we're going to talk
about storage allocation.
This is a continuation
from last lecture
where we talked about
serial storage allocation.
Today we'll also talk
a little bit more
about serial allocation.
But then I'll talk more about
parallel allocation and also
garbage collection.
So I want to just do a review
of some memory allocation
primitives.
So recall that you can use
malloc to allocate memory
from the heap.
And if you call malloc
with the size of s,
it's going to
allocate and return
a pointer to a block of memory
containing at least s bytes.
So you might actually
get more than s bytes,
even though you
asked for s bytes.
But it's guaranteed to
give you at least s bytes.
The return values avoid star,
but good programming practice
is to typecast this
pointer to whatever type
you're using this memory
for when you receive
this from the malloc call.
There's also aligned allocation.
So you can do aligned
allocation with memalign,
which takes two arguments, a
size a as well as a size s.
And a has to be an
exact power of 2,
and it's going to
allocate and return
a pointer to a block of
memory again containing
at least s bytes.
But this time this
memory is going
to be aligned to
a multiple of a,
so the address is going
to be a multiple of a,
where this memory block starts.
So does anyone know why we might
want to do an aligned memory
allocation?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so one reason is
that you can align
memories so that they're
aligned to cache lines, so that
when you access an object that
fits within the
cache line, it's not
going to cross two cache lines.
And you'll only get one
cache axis instead of two.
So one reason is that
you want to align
the memory to cache
lines to reduce
the number of cache misses.
You get another reason is that
the vectorization operators
also require you to have
memory addresses that
are aligned to some power of 2.
So if you align your memory
allocation with memalign,
then that's also good
for the vector units.
We also talked
about deallocations.
You can free memory back to the
heap with the free function.
So if you pass at a point of
p to some block of memory,
it's going to
deallocate this block
and return it to the
storage allocator.
And we also talked about
some anomalies of freeing.
So what is it called
when you fail to free
some memory that you allocated?
Yes?
Yeah, so If you fail to freeze
something that you allocated,
that's called a memory leak.
And this can cause your program
to use more and more memory.
And eventually your
program is going
to use up all the
memory on your machine,
and it's going to crash.
We also talked about freeing
something more than once.
Does anyone remember
what that's called?
Yeah?
Yeah, so that's
called double freeing.
Double freeing is when you
free something more than once.
And the behavior is
going to be undefined.
You might get a seg
fault immediately,
or you'll free something
that was allocated
for some other purpose.
And then later down
the road your program
is going to have some
unexpected behavior.
OK.
I also want to talk about m map.
So m map is a system call.
And usually m map is used
to treat some file on disk
as part of memory,
so that when you
write to that memory region,
it also backs it up on disk.
In this context
here, I'm actually
using m map to allocate
virtual memory without having
any backing file.
So
So our map has a whole
bunch of parameters here.
The second to the last
parameter indicates
the file I want to map,
and if I pass a negative 1,
that means there's
no backing file.
So I'm just using this to
allocate some virtual memory.
The first argument is where
I want to allocate it.
And 0 means that I don't care.
The size in terms
of number of bytes
has how much memory
I want to allocate.
Then there's also permissions.
So here it says I can read
and write this memory region.
s private means that
this memory region
is private to the process
that's allocating it.
And then map anon means that
there is no name associated
with this memory region.
And then as I said,
negative 1 means
that there's no backing file.
And the last parameter is just
0 if there's no backing file.
Normally it would be
an offset into the file
that you're trying to map.
But here there's
no backing file.
And what m map does is it finds
a contiguous unused region
in the address space of the
application that's large enough
to hold size bytes.
And then it updates
the page table
so that it now contains
an entry for the pages
that you allocated.
And then it creates a necessary
virtual memory management
structures within
the operating system
to make it so that users
accesses to this area
are legal, and accesses
won't result in a seg fault.
If you try to access some
region of memory without using--
without having OS
set these parameters,
then you might get a set fault
because the program might not
have permission to
access that area.
But m map is going to make
sure that the user can access
this area of virtual memory.
And m map is a system
call, whereas malloc,
which we talked about last
time, is a library call.
So these are two
different things.
And malloc actually uses
m map under the hood
to get more memory from
the operating system.
So let's look at some
properties of m map.
So m map is lazy.
So when you request a
certain amount of memory,
it doesn't immediately
allocate physical memory
for the requested allocation.
Instead it just
populates the page table
with entries pointing
to a special 0 page.
And then it marks these
pages as read only.
And then the first time
you write to such a page,
it will cause a page
fault. And at that point,
the OS is going to
modify the page table,
get the appropriate
physical memory,
and store the mapping from
the virtual address space
to physical address space
for the particular page
that you touch.
And then it will
restart the instructions
so that it can
continue to execute.
You can-- turns out
that you can actually
m map a terabyte
of virtual memory,
even on a machine with
just a gigabyte of d ram.
Because when you call m
map, it doesn't actually
allocate the physical memory.
But then you should be careful,
because a process might
die from running out
of physical memory
well after you call m map.
Because m map is going to
allocate this physical memory
whenever you first touch it.
And this could be much
later than when you actually
made the call to m map.
So any questions so far?
OK.
So what's the difference
between malloc and m map?
So as I said, malloc
is a library call.
And it's part of--malloc and
free are part of the memory
allocation interface of the
heat-management code in the c
library.
And the heat-management code
uses the available system
facilities, including
the m map function
to get a virtual address space
from the operating system.
And then the
heat-management code
is going-- within
malloc-- is going
to attempt to satisfy user
requests for heat storage
by reusing the memory
that it got from the OS
as much as possible until
it can't do that anymore.
And then it will
go and call m map
to get more memory from
the operating system.
So the malloc implementation
invokes m map and other system
calls to expand the size
of the users heap storage.
And the responsibility
of malloc is
to reuse the memory, such that
your fragmentation is reduced,
and you have good
temporal locality,
whereas the
responsibility of m map
is actually getting this memory
from the operating system.
So any questions
on the differences
between malloc and m map?
So one question is,
why don't we just call
m map up all the time,
instead of just using malloc?
Why don't we just
directly call m map?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yes,
so one answer is
that you might have
free storage from before
that you would want to reuse.
And it turns out that m map
is relatively heavy weight.
So it works on a
page granularity.
So if you want to do
a small allocation,
it's quite wasteful to
allocate an entire page
for that allocation
and not reuse it.
You'll get very bad
external fragmentation.
And when you call
m map, it has to go
through all of the overhead
of the security of the OS
and updating the
page table and so on.
Whereas, if you use
malloc, it's actually
pretty fast for
most allocations,
and especially if you have
temporal locality where
you allocate something that
you just recently freed.
So your program
would be pretty slow
if you used m map all the time,
even for small allocations.
For big allocations, it's fine.
But for small allocations,
you should use malloc.
Any questions on m
map versus malloc?
OK, so I just want to do
a little bit of review
on how address
translation works.
So some of you might have seen
this before in your computer
architecture course.
So how it works is, when
you access memory location,
you access it via
the virtual address.
And the virtual address can be
divided into two parts, where
the lower order bits
store the offset,
and the higher order bits
store the virtual page number.
And in order to get the
physical address associated
with this virtual
address, the hardware
is going to look up this
virtual page number in what's
called the page table.
And then if it finds
a corresponding entry
for the virtual page
number in the page table,
that will tell us the
physical frame number.
And then the
physical frame number
corresponds to where this
fiscal memory is in d ram.
So you can just take
the frame number,
and then use the
same offset as before
to get the appropriate offset
into the physical memory frame.
So if the virtual page
that you're looking for
doesn't reside in
physical memory,
then a page fault
is going to occur.
And when a page fault occurs,
either the operating system
will see that the
process actually
has permissions to look
at that memory region,
and it will set the
permissions and place the entry
into the page table
so that you can
get the appropriate
physical address.
But otherwise, the
operating system
might see that this
process actually
can't access that region
memory, and then you'll
get a segmentation fault.
It turns out that the page
table search, also called a page
walk, is pretty expensive.
And that's why we have the
translation look, a side
buffer or TLB,
which is essentially
a cache for the page table.
So the hardware uses a TLB
to cache the recent page
table look ups into this
TLB so that later on when
you access the same
page, it doesn't
have to go all the
way to the page table
to find the physical address.
It can first look
in the TLB to see
if it's been recently accessed.
So why would you
expect to see something
that it recently has accessed?
So what's one
property of a program
that will make it so that
you get a lot of TLB hits?
Yes?
STUDENT: Well, usually
[INAUDIBLE] nearby one another,
which means they're probably in
the same page or [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so that's correct.
So the page table
stores pages, which
are typically four kilobytes.
Nowadays there are
also huge pages, which
can be a couple of megabytes.
And most of the
accesses in your program
are going to be near each other.
So they're likely
going to reside
on the same page for
accesses that have been
done close together in time.
So therefore you'll expect that
many of your recent accesses
are going to be
stored in the TLB
if your program has locality,
either spatial or temporal
locality or both.
So how this architecture works
is that the processor is first
going to check whether
the virtual address you're
looking for is in TLB.
If it's not, it's going to go to
the page table and look it up.
And then if it finds
that there, then it's
going to store that
entry into the TLB.
And then next it's going to
go get this physical address
that it found from the TLB and
look it up into the CPU cache.
And if it finds it
there, it gets it.
If it doesn't, then it goes to
d ram to satisfy the request.
Most modern machines
actually have an optimization
that allow you to do TLB access
in parallel with the L1 cache
access.
So the L1 cache actually uses
virtual addresses instead
of fiscal addresses,
and this reduces
the latency of a memory access.
So that's a brief review
of address translation.
All right, so let's
talk about stacks.
So when you execute a
serial c and c++ program,
you're using a stack to keep
track of the function calls
and local variables
that you have to save.
So here, let's say we
have this invocation tree,
where function a calls
Function b, which then returns.
And then a calls
function c, which
calls d, returns, calls e,
returns, and then returns
again.
Here are the different views of
the stack at different points
of the execution.
So initially when we call a,
we have a stack frame for a.
And then when a
calls b, we're going
to place a stack
frame for b right
below the stack frame of a.
So these are going to
be linearly ordered.
When we're done with b,
then this part of the stack
is no longer going to
be used, the part for b.
And then when it calls c, It's
going to allocate a stack frame
below a on the stack.
And this space is actually going
to be the same space as what
b was using before.
But this is fine, because we're
already done with the call
to b.
Then when c calls d, we're going
to create a stack frame for d
right below c.
When it returns, we're not going
to use that space any more,
so then we can reuse it for
the stack frame when we call e.
And then eventually all
of these will pop back up.
And all of these views
here share the same view
of the stack frame for a.
And then for c, d, and e, they
all stare share the same view
of this stack for c.
So this is how a traditional
linear stack works when you
call a serial c or c++ program.
And you can view this as a
serial walk over the invocation
tree.
There's one rule for pointers.
With traditional
linear stacks is
that a parent can pass
pointers to its stack variables
down to its children.
But not the other way around.
A child can't pass a pointer
to some local variable
back to its parent.
So if you do that, you'll
get a bug in your program.
How many of you have
tried doing that before?
Yeah, so a lot of you.
So let's see why that
causes a problem.
So if I'm calling--
if I call b, and I pass a
pointer to some local variable
in b stack to a, and
then now when a calls c,
It's going to overwrite
the space that b was using.
And if b's local variable
was stored in the space
that c has now
overwritten, then you're
just going to see garbage.
And when you try to
access that, you're
not going to get
the correct value.
So you can pass a pointer
to a's local variable
down to any of these
descendant function
calls, because they all see
the same view of a stack.
And that's not going
to be overwritten
while these descendant
function calls are proceeding.
But if you pass it the
other way, then potentially
the variable that
you had a pointer to
is going to be overwritten.
So here's one question.
If you want to pass memory from
a child back to the parent,
where would you allocate it?
So you can allocate
it on the parent.
What's another option?
Yes?
Yes, so another way to do this
is to allocate it on the heap.
If you allocate it on
the heap, even after you
return from the function
call, that memory
is going to persist.
You can also allocate it in the
parent's stack, if you want.
In fact, some programs
are written that way.
And one of the reasons why
many c functions require
you to pass in memory to
the function where it's
going to store the
return value is
to try to avoid an expensive
heap allocation in the child.
Because if the parent allocates
this space to store the result,
the child can just
put whatever it
wants to compute in that space.
And the parent will see it.
So then the responsibility
is up to the parent
to figure out whether it
wants to allocate the memory
on the stack or on the heap.
So this is one of
the reasons why
you'll see many c functions,
where one of the arguments
is a memory location where
the result should be stored.
OK, so that was the serial case.
What happens in parallel?
So in parallel, we
have what's called
a cactus stack where we
can support multiple views
of the stack in parallel.
So let's say we have a program
where it calls function
a, and then a spawns b and c.
So b and c are going to
be running potentially
in parallel.
And then c spawns d and
e, which can potentially
be running in parallel.
So for this program, we could
have functions b, d and e all
executing in parallel.
And a cactus stack
is going to allow
us to have all of
these functions
see the same view of
this stack as they
would have if this program
were executed serially.
And the silk runtime
system supports
the cactus stack to make it easy
for writing parallel programs.
Because now when you're
writing programs,
you just have to obey the same
rules for programming in serial
c and c++ with
regards to the stack,
and then you'll still get
the intended behavior.
And it turns out that there's
no copying of the stacks here.
So all of these
different views are
seeing the same virtual
memory addresses for a.
But now there is
an issue of how do
we implement this cactus stack?
Because in the serial case, we
could have these later stacks
overwriting the earlier stacks.
But in parallel,
how can we do this?
So does anyone have
any simple ideas
on how we can implement
a cactus stack?
Yes?
STUDENT: You could just have
each child's stack start
in like a separate stack,
or just have references
to the [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so one way to do this
is to have each thread
use a different stack.
And then store pointers to
the different stack frames
across the different stacks.
There's actually another way
to do this, which is easier.
OK, yes?
STUDENT: If the stack
frames have a maximum--
fixed maximum size--
then you could put them
all in the same stack
separated by that fixed size.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so if the stacks all
have a maximum depth,
then you could just
allocate a whole bunch of
stacks, which are separated
by this maximum depth.
There's actually
another way to do this,
which is to not use the stack.
So yes?
STUDENT: Could you memory
map it somewhere else--
each of the different threads?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, that's
actually one way to do it.
The easiest way to do it is just
to allocate it off the heap.
So instead of allocating
the frames on the stack,
you just do a heap allocation
for each of these stack frames.
And then each of
these stack frames
has a pointer to the
parent stack frame.
So whenever you do
a function call,
you're going to do a memory
allocation from the heap
to get a new stack frame.
And then when you
finish a function,
you're going to pop
something off of this stack,
and free it back to the heap.
In fact, a lot of early systems
for parallel programming
use this strategy of
heap-based cactus stacks.
Turns out that you can actually
minimize the performance
impact using this strategy if
you optimize the code enough.
But there is actually
a bigger problem
with using a heap-based
cactus stack, which doesn't
have to do with performance.
Does anybody have any guesses
of what this potential issue is?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It requires you to
allocate the heap in parallel.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
let's assume that we can
do parallel heap allocation.
And we'll talk about that.
So assuming that we
can do that correctly,
what's the issue
with this approach?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's that you don't
know how big the stack is
going to be?
JULIAN SHUN: So
let's assume that you
can get whatever stack frames
you need from the heap,
so you don't actually need to
put an upper bound on this.
Yeah?
STUDENT: We don't know
the maximum depth.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So we don't know
the maximum depth,
but let's say we
can make that work.
So you don't actually need
to know the maximum depth
if you're allocating
off the heap.
Any other guesses?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Something
to do with returning
from the stack that is
allocated on the heap
to one of the original stacks.
JULIAN SHUN: So let's say we
could get that to work as well.
So what happens if I try
to run some program using
this heap-based cactus
stack with something
that's using the regular stack?
So let's say I have
some old legacy
code that was already
compiled using
the traditional linear stack.
So there's a problem with
interoperability here.
Because the traditional
code is assuming
that, when you make
a function call,
the stack frame for
the function call
is going to appear right
after the stack frame
for the particular
call e function.
So if you try to mix code that
uses the traditional stack as
well as this heap-based
cactus stack approach,
then it's not going
to work well together.
One approach is
that you can just
recompile all your code to use
this heap-based cactus stack.
Even if you could do that,
even if all of the source codes
were available, there
are some legacy programs
that actually in
the source code,
they do some manipulations
with the stack,
because they assume that you're
using the traditional stack,
and those programs
would no longer
work if you're using a
heap-based cactus stack.
So the problem is
interoperability
with legacy code.
Turns out that you can
fix this using an approach
called thread local
memory mapping.
So one of the students
mentioned memory mapping.
But that requires changes
to the operating system.
So it's not general purpose.
But the heap-based cactus stack
turns out to be very simple.
And we can prove
nice bounds about it.
So besides the
interoperability issue,
heap-based cactus stacks
are pretty good in practice,
as well as in theory.
So we can actually
prove a space bound
of a cilk program that uses
the heap-based cactus stack.
So let's say s 1 is the
stack space required
by a serial execution
of a cilk program.
Then the stack space
of p worker execution
using a heap-based cactus
stack is going to be
upper bounded by p times s 1.
So s p is the space for
a p worker execution,
and that's less than or
equal to p times s 1.
To understand how
this works, we need
to understand a little bit
about how the cilks works
stealing algorithm works.
So in the cilk
work-stealing algorithm,
whenever you spawn
something of work,
or that spawns a new task,
is going to work on the task
that it spawned.
So therefore, for any leaf
in the invocation tree that
currently exists,
there's always going
to be a worker working on it.
There's not going to be
any leaves in the tree
where there's no
worker working on it.
Because when a worker spawns
a task, it creates a new leaf.
But then it works
immediately on that leaf.
So here we have a--
we have a invocation tree.
And for all of the leaves, we
have a processor working on it.
And with this busy
leaves property,
we can easily show
this space bound.
So for each one of
these processors,
the maximum stack
space it's using
is going to be upper
bounded by s 1,
because that's maximum stock
space across a serial execution
that executes the whole program.
And then since we have
p of these leaves,
we just multiply s 1
by p, and that gives us
an upper bound on the overall
space used by a p worker
execution.
This can be a loose upper
bound, because we're double
counting here.
There's some part of
this memory that we're
counting more than once,
because they're shared
among the different processors.
But that's why we have the
less than or equal to here.
So it's upper bounded
by p times s 1.
So this is one of
the nice things
about using a heap-based
cactus stack is that you
get this good space bound.
Any questions on the
space bound here?
So let's try to apply this
theorem to a real example.
So this is the divide and
conquer matrix multiplication
code that we saw in
a previous lecture.
So this is-- in this code, we're
making eight recursive calls
to a divide and
conquer function.
Each of size n over 2.
And before we make
any of these calls,
we're doing a malloc to
get some temporary space.
And this is of size
order and squared.
And then we free this
temporary space at the end.
And notice here
that the allocations
of the temporary matrix
obey a stack discipline.
So we're allocating stuff
before we make recursive calls.
And we're freeing it
after, or right before we
return from the function.
So all this stack--
all the allocations
are nested, and they
follow a stack discipline.
And it turns out that even
if you're allocating off
the heap, if you follow
a stack discipline,
you can still use the space
bound from the previous slide
to upper bound the
p worker space.
OK, so let's try to analyze
the space of this code here.
So first let's look at
what the work and span are.
So this is just
going to be review.
What's the work of this divide
and conquer matrix multiply?
So it's n cubed.
So it's n cubed because we
have eight solve problems
of size n over 2.
And then we have
to do linear work
to add together the matrices.
So our recurrence is
going to be t 1 of n
is equal to eight times t 1 of
n over 2 plus order n squared.
And that solves to order n
cubed if you just pull out
your master theorem card.
What about the span?
So what's the recurrence here?
Yeah, so the span
t infinity of n
is equal to t
infinitive of n over 2
plus a span of the addition.
And what's the span
of the addition?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: No,
let's assume that we
have a parallel addition.
We have nested silk four loops.
Right, so then the span of
that is just going of be log n.
Since the span of 1
silk four loop is log n
and when you nest them, you
just add together the span.
So it's going to
be t infinity of n
is equal to t infinity of
n over 2 plus order log n.
And what does that solve to?
Yeah, so it's going to solve
to order log squared n.
Again you can pull out
your master theorem card,
and look at one of
the three cases.
OK, so now let's
look at the space.
What's going to be the
recurrence for the space?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: The only place
we're generating new space
is when we call
this malloc here.
So they're all seeing
the same original matrix.
So what would the recurrence be?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
JULIAN SHUN: So the n
square term is right.
Do we actually need eight
subproblems of size n over 2?
What happens after we finish
one of these sub problems?
Are we still going to
use the space for it?
STUDENT: Yeah, you free the
memory after the [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So you can actually
reuse the memory.
Because you free the
memory you allocated
after each one of
these recursive calls.
So therefore the recurrence is
just going to be s of n over 2
plus theta n squared.
And what does that solve to?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: N squared.
Right.
So here the n squared
term actually dominates.
You have a decreasing
geometric series.
So it's dominated at the root,
and you get theta of n squared.
And therefore by using the busy
leaves property and the theorem
for the space bound, this
tells us that on p processors,
the space is going to be
bounded by p times n squared.
And this is actually pretty good
since we have a bound on this.
It turns out that we can
actually prove a stronger bound
for this particular example.
And I'll walk you through how we
can prove this stronger bound.
Here's the order p times n
squared is already pretty good.
But we can actually do better
if we look internally at how
this algorithm is structured.
So on each level of recursion,
we're branching eight ways.
And most of the
space is going to be
used near the top of
this recursion tree.
So if I branch as
much as possible
near the top of
my recursion tree,
then that's going to give me
my worst case space bound.
Because the space is
decreasing geometrically as I
go down the tree.
So I'm going to
branch eight ways
until I get to some level
k in the recursion tree
where I have p nodes.
And at that point, I'm not going
to branch anymore because I've
already used up all p nodes.
And that's the number
of workers I have.
So let's say I have this level
k here, where I have p nodes.
So what would be
the value of k here?
If I branch eight ways
how many levels do
I have to go until
I get to p nodes?
Yes.
STUDENT: It's log base 8 of p.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
It's log base 8 of p.
So we have eight,
the k, equal p,
because we're branching k ways.
And then using some
algebra, you can get it
so that k is equal to log base
8 of p, which is equal to log
base 2 of p divided by 3.
And then at this
level k downwards,
it's going to decrease
geometrically.
So the space is going to be
dominant at this level k.
So the space decreases
geometrically
as you go down from level k, and
also as you go up from level k.
So therefore we can just look at
what the space is at this level
k here.
So the space is going to be
p times the size of each one
of these nodes squared.
And the size of each
one of these nodes
is going to be n over 2 to
the log base 2 of p over 3.
And then we square that
because we're using
n squared temporary space.
So if you solve that, that gives
you p to the one-third times n
squared, which is better
than the upper bound
we saw earlier of order
p times n squared.
So you can work out the
details for this example.
Not all the details are
shown on this slide.
You need to show that the
level k here actually dominates
all the other levels
in the recursion tree.
But in general, if you know what
the structure of the algorithm,
is you can potentially prove a
stronger space bound than just
applying the general theorem we
showed on the previous slide.
So any questions on this?
OK, so as I said before, the
problem with heap-based linkage
is that parallel functions
fail to interoperate
with legacy and third-party
serial binaries.
Yes, was there a question?
STUDENT: I actually
do have a question.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: How do we know
that the workers don't split
along the path of the
[INAUDIBLE] instead of across
or horizontal.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So you don't actually know that.
But this turns out
to be the worst case.
So if it branches any
other way, the space
is just going to be lower.
So you have to argue that this
is going to be the worst case,
and it's going to be--
intuitively it's the
worst case, because you're
using most of the memory near
the root of the recursion tree.
So if you can get all p nodes as
close as possible to the root,
that's going to make your
space as high as possible.
It's a good question.
So parallel functions
fail to interoperate
with legacy and third-party
serial binaries.
Even if you can recompile
all of this code, which
isn't always
necessarily the case,
you can still have
issues if the legacy code
is taking advantage of the
traditional linear stack
inside the source code.
So our implementation of
cilk uses a less space
efficient strategy that is
interoperable with legacy code.
And it uses a pool of
linear stacks instead
of a heap-based strategy.
So we're going to maintain a
pool of linear stacks lying
around.
There's going to be more
than p stacks lying around.
And whenever a worker
tries to steal something,
it's going to try to
acquire one of these tasks
from this pool of linear tasks.
And when it's done, it
will return it back.
But when it finds
that there's no more
linear stacks in
this pool, then it's
not going to steal anymore.
So this is still going to
preserve the space bound,
as long as the number of stocks
is a constant times the number
of processors.
But it will affect
the time bounds
of the work-stealing algorithm.
Because now when
a worker is idle,
it might not necessarily
have the chance
to steal if there are no
more stacks lying around.
This strategy doesn't
require any changes
to the operating system.
There is a way where you
can preserve the space
and the time bounds using
thread local memory mapping.
But this does require changes
to the operating system.
So our implementation of cilk
uses a pool of linear stacks,
and it's based on the
Intel implementation.
OK.
All right, so we
talked about stacks,
and that we just reduce the
problem to heap allocation.
So now we have to
talk about heaps.
So let's review some
basic properties
of heap-storage allocators.
So here's a definition.
The allocator
speed is the number
of allocations and d
allocations per second
that the allocator can sustain.
And here's a question.
Is it more important to
maximize the allocator speed
for large blocks
or small blocks?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Small blocks?
JULIAN SHUN: So small blocks.
Here's another question.
Why?
Yes?
STUDENT: So you're going to
be doing a lot of [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yes,
so one answer is
that you're going to be
doing a lot more allocations
and deallocations of small
blocks than large blocks.
There's actually a
more fundamental reason
why it's more important to
optimize for small blocks.
So anybody?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
basically not being
able to make use of pages.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
that's another reason
for small blocks.
It's more likely that it
will lead to fragmentation
if you don't optimize
for small blocks.
What's another reason?
Yes.
STUDENT: Wouldn't
it just take longer
to allocate larger
blocks anyway?
So the overhead is going to
be more noticeable if you have
a big overhead when you
allocate small blocks
versus large blocks?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the reason-- the main reason
is that when you're allocating
a large--
when you're allocating
a block, a user program
is typically going to write
to all the bytes in the block.
And therefore,
for a large block,
it takes so much time to
write that the allocator
time has little effect on
the overall running time.
Whereas if a program
allocates many small blocks,
the amount of
work-- useful work--
it's actually doing on
the block is going to be--
it can be comparable to the
overhead for the allocation.
And therefore, all of
the allocation overhead
can add up to a significant
amount for small blocks.
So essentially for
large blocks, you
can amortize away the overheads
for storage allocation,
whereas for small, small
blocks, it's harder to do that.
Therefore, it's important to
optimize for small blocks.
Here's another definition.
So the user footprint
is the maximum
over time of the
number u of bytes
in use by the user program.
And these are the bytes that
are allocated and not freed.
And this is measuring
the peak memory usage.
It's not necessarily equal
to the sum of the sizes
that you have allocated
so far, because you
might have reused some of that.
So the user footprint is the
peak memory usage and number
of bytes.
And the allocator
footprint is the maximum
over time of the
number of a bytes
that the memory
provided to the locator
by the operating system.
And the reason why the allocator
footprint could be larger
than the user
footprint, is that when
you ask the OS for some
memory, it could give you
more than what you asked for.
And similarly, if you ask malloc
for some amount of memory,
it can also give you more
than what you asked for.
And the fragmentation is
defined to be a divided by u.
And a program with
low fragmentation
will keep this ratio
as low as possible,
so keep the allocator
footprint as close as
possible to the user footprint.
And in the best case, this
ratio is going to be one.
So you're using
all of the memory
that the operating
system allocated.
One remark is that the
allocator footprint
a usually gross monotonically
for many allocators.
So it turns out
that many allocators
do m maps to get more memory.
But they don't always free
this memory back to the OS.
And you can actually free
memory using something called
m unmap, which is the
opposite of m map,
to give memory back to the OS.
But this turns out to
be pretty expensive.
In modern operating systems,
their implementation
is not very efficient.
So many allocators
don't use m unmap.
You can also use
something called m advise.
And what m advise does is it
tells the operating system
that you're not going to
be using this page anymore
but to keep it around
in virtual memory.
So this has less
overhead, because it
doesn't have to clear this
entry from the page table.
It just has to mark
that the program isn't
using this page anymore.
So some allocators use m
advise with the option,
don't need, to free memory.
But a is usually still growing
monotonically over time,
because allocators
don't necessarily
free all of the things back
to the OS that they allocated.
Here's a theorem that we proved
in last week's lecture, which
says that the fragmentation
for binned free list
is order log base 2 of
u, or just order log u.
And the reason for
this is that you're
can have log-based 2 of u bins.
And for each bin
it can basically
contain u bytes of storage.
So overall you can use--
overall, you could
have allocated
u times log u storage, and
only be using u of those bytes.
So therefore the
fragmentation is order log u.
Another thing to note is that
modern 64-bit processors only
provide about 2 to 48 bytes
of virtual address space.
So this is sort of news
because you would probably
expect that, for a
64-bit processor,
you have to the 64 bytes
of virtual address space.
But that turns out
not to be the case.
So they only support
to the 48 bytes.
And that turns out to be
enough for all of the programs
that you would want to write.
And that's also going to be much
more than the physical memory
you would have on a machine.
So nowadays, you
can get a big server
with a terabyte of memory,
or to the 40th bytes
of physical memory,
which is still
much lower than the number of
bytes in the virtual address
space.
Any questions?
OK, so here's some
more definitions.
So the space overhead
of an allocator
is a space used for bookkeeping.
So you could store--
perhaps you could store
headers with the blocks
that you allocate to
keep track of the size
and other information.
And that would contribute
to the space overhead
Internal fragmentation
is a waste
due to allocating larger
blocks in the user request.
So you can get
internal fragmentation
if, when you call
malloc, you get back
a block that's actually larger
than what the user requested.
We saw on the bin
free list algorithm,
we're rounding up to the
nearest power of 2's.
If you allocate
nine bytes, you'll
actually get back 16 bytes in
our binned-free list algorithm
from last lecture.
So that contributes to
internal fragmentation.
It turns out that not
all binned-free list
implementations use powers of 2.
So some of them use other
powers that are smaller than 2
in order to reduce the
internal fragmentation.
Then there's an
external fragmentation,
which is the waste due to
the inability to use storage
because it's not contiguous.
So for example, if I allocated
a whole bunch of one byte things
consecutively in memory, then
I freed every other byte.
And now I want to
allocate a 2-byte thing,
I don't actually have contiguous
mammary to satisfy that
request, because all
of my free memory--
all of my free bytes
are in one-bite chunks,
and they're not
next to each other.
So this is one example of how
external fragmentation can
happen after you allocate
stuff and free stuff.
Then there's blow up.
And this is for a
parallel locator.
The additional space beyond what
a serial locator would require.
So if a serial locator
requires s space,
and a parallel allocator
requires t space,
then it's just going
to be t over s.
That's the blow up.
OK, so now let's look at
some parallel heap allocation
strategies.
So the first strategy
is to use a global heap.
And this is how the
default c allocator works.
So if you just use a default
c allocator out of the box,
this is how it's implemented.
It uses a global heap
where all the accesses
to this global heap
are protected by mutex.
You can also use lock-free
synchronization primitives
to implement this.
We'll actually talk about
some of these synchronization
primitives later
on in the semester.
And this is done to
preserve atomicity
because you can have
multiple threads trying
to access the global
heap at the same time.
And you need to ensure that
races are handled correctly.
So what's the blow
up for this strategy?
How much more space am I using
than just a serial allocator?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
the blow up is one.
Because I'm not actually
using any more space
than the serial allocator.
Since I'm just maintaining
one global heap, and everybody
is going to that heap to do
allocations and deallocations.
But what's the potential
issue with this approach?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Performance hit
for that block coordination.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so you're going
to take a performance hit for
trying to acquire this lock.
So basically every time you do
a allocation or deallocation,
you have to acquire this lock.
And this is pretty
slow, and it gets
slower as you increase
the number of processors.
Roughly speaking,
acquiring a lock to perform
is similar to an
L2 cache access.
And if you just run
a serial allocator,
many of your requests are
going to be satisfied just
by going into the L1 cache.
Because you're going
to be allocating
things that you recently
freed, and those things
are going to be
residing in L1 cache.
But here, before you
even get started,
you have to grab a lock.
And you have to pay
a performance hit
similar to an L2 cache access.
So that's bad.
And it gets worse
as you increase
the number of processors.
So the contention
increases as you
increase the number of threads.
And then you can't--
you're not going to be able
to get good scalability.
So ideally, as the number of
threads or processors grows,
the time to perform an
allocation or deallocation
shouldn't increase.
But in fact, it does.
And the most common reason
for loss of scalability
is lock contention.
So here all of the
processes are trying
to acquire the same lock, which
is the same memory address.
And if you recall from
the caching lecture,
or the multicore
programming lecture,
every time you acquire
a memory location,
you have to bring that cache
line into your own cache,
and then invalidate
the same cache line
in other processors' caches.
So if all the processors
are doing this,
then this cache line is
going to be bouncing around
among all of the
processors' caches,
and this could lead to
very bad performance.
So here's a question.
Is lock contention more of
a problem for large blocks
or small blocks?
Yes.
STUDENT: So small blocks.
JULIAN SHUN: Here's
another question.
Why?
Yes.
STUDENT: Because by
the time it takes
to finish using the
small block, then
the allocator is usually small.
So you do many allocations
and deallocations,
which means you have to go
through the lock multiple
times.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So one of the
reasons is that when
you're doing small
allocations, that
means that your request rate
is going to be pretty high.
And your processors are going
to be spending a lot of time
acquiring this lock.
And this can exacerbate
the lock contention.
And another reason is that when
you allocate a large block,
you're doing a lot of work,
because you have to write--
most of the time you're
going to write to all
the bytes in that large block.
And therefore you can
amortize the overheads
of the storage allocator
across all of the work
that you're doing.
Whereas for small
blocks, in addition to
increasing this rate of
memory requests, it's also--
there's much less work to
amortized to overheads across.
So any questions?
OK, good.
All right.
So here's another strategy,
which is to use local heaps.
So each thread is going
to maintain its own heap.
And it's going to allocate
out of its own heap.
And there's no locking
that's necessary.
So when you allocate something,
you get it from your own heap.
And when you free something, you
put it back into your own heap.
So there's no
synchronization required.
So that's a good thing.
It's very fast.
What's a potential issue
with this approach?
Yes.
STUDENT: It's using
a lot of extra space.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes,
so this approach,
you're going to be using
a lot of extra space.
So first of all,
because you have
to maintain multiple heaps.
And what's one
phenomenon that you
might see if you're
executing a program
with this local-heap approach?
So it's a space--
could the space potentially
keep growing over time?
Yes.
STUDENT: You could
maybe like allocate
every one process [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
Yeah, so you could actually
have an unbounded blow up.
Because if you do all of
the allocations in one heap,
and you free everything
in another heap,
then whenever the first
heap does an allocation,
there's actually free space
sitting around in another heap.
But it's just going to grab
more memory from the operating
system.
So you're blow up
can be unbounded.
And this phenomenon, it's
what's called memory drift.
So blocks allocated
by one thread
are freed by another thread.
And if you run your
program for long enough,
your memory consumption
can keep increasing.
And this is sort of
like a memory leak.
So you might see that if you
have a memory drift problem,
your program running
on multiple processors
could run out of
memory eventually.
Whereas if you just run
it on a single core,
it won't run out of memory.
And here it's because the
allocator isn't smart enough
to reuse things in other heaps.
So what's another strategy you
can use to try to fix this?
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry, can
you repeat your question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Because
if you keep allocating
from one thread, if you
do all of your allocations
in one thread, and do
all of your deallocations
on another thread,
every time you
allocate from the
first thread, there's
actually memory sitting
around in the system.
But the first thread isn't
going to see it, because it only
sees its own heap.
And it's just going
to keep grabbing
more memory from the OS.
And then the second
thread actually
has this extra memory
sitting around.
But it's not using it.
Because it's only
doing the freeze.
It's not doing allocate.
And if we recall the
definition of blow up
is, how much more
space you're using
compared to a serial
execution of a program.
If you executed this
program on a single core,
you would only have a single
heap that does the allocations
and frees.
So you're not going to--
your memory isn't
going to blow up.
It's just going to be
constant over time.
Whereas if you use two
threads to execute this,
the memory could just
keep growing over time.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: So, it just--
so if you remember the
binned-free list approach,
let's say we're using that.
Then all you have to
do is set some pointers
in your binned-free
lists data structure,
as well as the block
that you're freeing,
so that it appears in
one of the linked lists.
So you can do that even if
some other processor allocated
that block.
OK, so what what's another
strategy that can avoid
this issue of memory drift?
Yes?
STUDENT: Periodically shuffle
the free memory that's
being used on different heaps.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So that's a good idea.
You could periodically
rebalance the memory.
What's a simpler approach
to solve this problem?
Yes?
STUDENT: Make it all know
all of the free memory?
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry,
could you repeat that?
STUDENT: Make them all know
all of the free memory?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So you could have
all of the processors
know all the free memory.
And then every time
it grabs something,
it looks in all the other heaps.
That does require a lot of
synchronization overhead.
Might not perform that well.
What's an easier way
to solve this problem?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: So you could
restructure your program
so that the same thread
does the allocation
and frees for the
same memory block.
But what if you didn't want
to restructure your program?
How can you change
the allocator?
So we want the
behavior that you said,
but we don't want to
change our program.
Yes.
STUDENT: You could have
a single free list that's
protected by synchronization.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so you
could have a single free list.
But that gets back
to the first strategy
of having a global heap.
And then you have high
synchronization overheads.
Yes.
STUDENT: You could have
the free map to the thread
that it came from or for the
pointer that corresponds to--
that allocated it.
JULIAN SHUN: So you're
saying free back
to the thread that allocated it?
Yes, so that that's
exactly right.
So here each object,
when you allocate it,
it's labeled with an owner.
And then whenever
you free it, you
return it back to the owner.
So the objects
that are allocated
will eventually go back
to the owner's heap
if they're not in use.
And they're not going
to be free lying around
in somebody else's heap.
The advantage of
this approach is
that you get fast allocation
and freeing of local objects.
Local objects are objects
that you allocated.
However, free remote objects
require some synchronization.
Because you have to coordinate
with the other threads' heap
that you're sending the
memory object back to.
But this synchronization isn't
as bad as having a global heap,
since you only have to talk to
one other thread in this case.
You can also bound
the blow up by p.
So the reason why the blow
up is upper bounded by p
is that, let's say the
serial allocator uses
at most x memory.
In this case, each of the
heaps can use at most x memory,
because that's how much the
serial program would have used.
And you have p of these
heaps, so overall you're
using p times x memory.
And therefore the ratio
is upper bounded by p.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: So when you
free an object, it goes--
if you allocated that object,
it goes back to your own heap.
If your heap is
empty, it's actually
going to get more memory
from the operating system.
It's not going to take something
from another thread's heap.
But the maximum amount of memory
that you're going to allocate
is going to be
upper bounded by x.
Because the sequential serial
program took that much.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the upper bound
for the blow up is p.
Another advantage
of this approach
is that it's resilience--
it has resilience
to false sharing.
So let me just talk a little
bit about false sharing.
So true sharing is
when two processors
are trying to access the
same memory location.
And false sharing is when
multiple processors are
accessing different
memory locations,
but those locations happen
to be on the same cache line.
So here's an example.
Let's say we have two
variables, x and y.
And the compiler happens to
place x and y on the same cache
line.
Now, when the first
processor writes to x,
it's going to bring this
cache line into its cache.
When the other
processor writes to y,
since it's on the
same cache line,
it's going to bring this
cache line to y's cache.
And then now, the first
processor writes x,
it's going to bring
this cache line back
to the first processor's cache.
And then you can keep--
you can see this
phenomenon keep happening.
So here, even though
the processors
are writing to different
memory locations,
because they happen to be
on the same cache line,
the cache line is going to
be bouncing back and forth
on the machine between the
different processors' caches.
And this problem gets
worse if more processors
are accessing this cache line.
So in this-- this can
be quite hard to debug.
Because if you're using
just variables on the stack,
you don't actually
know necessarily
where the compiler is going to
place these memory locations.
So the compiler
could just happen
to place x and y in
the same cache block.
And then you'll get
this performance hit,
even though it seems like you're
accessing different memory
locations.
If you're using the heap
for memory allocation,
you have more knowledge.
Because if you
allocate a huge block,
you know that all of
the memory locations
are contiguous in
physical memory.
So you can just space your--
you can space the accesses
far enough apart so
that different
processes aren't going
to touch the same cache line.
A more general approach
is that you can actually
pad the object.
So first, you can
align the object
on a cache line boundary.
And then you pad out the
remaining memory locations
of the objects so that it
fills up the entire cache line.
And now there's only one
thing on that cache line.
But this does lead
to a waste of space
because you have this
wasted padding here.
So program can
induce false sharing
by having different
threads process
nearby objects, both on
the stack and on the heap.
And then an allocator can
also induce false sharing
in two ways.
So it can actively
induce false sharing.
And this is when the allocator
satisfies memory requests
from different threads
using the same cache block.
And it can also
do this passively.
And this is when the program
passes objects lying around
in the same cache line.
So different threads,
and then the allocator
reuses the object
storage after the objects
are free to satisfy requests
from those different threads.
And the local ownership
approach tends
to reduce false sharing
because the thread that
allocates an object
is eventually
going to get it back.
You're not going to have it so
that an object is permanently
split among multiple
processors' heaps.
So even if you see false
sharing in local ownership,
it's usually temporary.
Eventually it's
going-- the object is
going to go back to the heap
that it was allocated from,
and the false sharing
is going to go away.
Yes?
STUDENT: Are the local heaps
just three to five regions in
[INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: I mean, you can
implement it in various ways.
I mean can have each one of
them have a binned-free list
allocator, so there's
no restriction
on where they have to
appear in physical memory.
There are many different
ways where you can--
you can basically plug-in
any serial locator
for the local heap.
So let's go back to
parallel heap allocation.
So I talked about three
approaches already.
Here's a fourth approach.
This is called the
hoard allocator.
And this was actually
a pretty good allocator
when it was introduced
almost two decades ago.
And it's inspired a
lot of further research
on how to improve
parallel-memory allocation.
So let me talk about
how this works.
So in the hoard allocator, we're
going to have p local heaps.
But we're also going
to have a global heap.
The memory is going
to be organized
into large super
blocks of size s.
And s is usually a
multiple of the page size.
So this is the
granularity at which
objects are going to be moved
around in the allocator.
And then you can move super
blocks between the local heaps
and the global heaps.
So when a local heap becomes--
has a lot of super blocks
that are not being fully used
and you can move it
to the global heap,
and then when a local heap
doesn't have enough memory,
it can go to the global
heap to get more memory.
And then when the global heap
doesn't have any more memory,
then it gets more memory
from the operating system.
So this is sort of a
combination of the approaches
that we saw before.
The advantages are that this
is a pretty fast allocator.
It's also scalable.
As you add more processors,
the performance improves.
You can also bound the blow up.
And it also has resilience
to false sharing,
because it's using local heaps.
So let's look at how an
allocation using the hoard
allocator works.
So let's just assume
without loss of generality
that all the blocks
are the same size.
So we have fixed-size
allocation.
So let's say we call
malloc in our program.
And let's say thread
i calls the malloc.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to check if there
is a free object in heap i
that can satisfy this request.
And if so, we're
going to get an object
from the fullest non-full
super block in i's heap.
Does anyone know why we want to
get the object from the fullest
non-full super block?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So when a super block
needs to be moved,
it's as dense as possible.
And more importantly, this is to
reduce external fragmentation.
Because as we saw
in the last lecture,
if you skew the distribution
of allocated memory objects
to as few pages,
or in this case,
as few super blocks
as possible, that
reduces your external
fragmentation.
OK, so if it finds
it in its own heap,
then it's going to allocate
an object from there.
Otherwise, it's going to
check the global heap.
And if there's something
in the global heap--
so here it says, if the
global heap is empty,
then it's going to get a
new super block from the OS.
Otherwise, we can get a super
block from the global heap,
and then use that one.
And then finally
we set the owner
of the block we got either from
the OS or from the global heap
to i, and then we return that
free object to the program.
So this is how a malloc works
using the hoard allocator.
And now let's look at
hoard deallocation.
Let use of i be the in
use storage in heap i.
This is the heap for thread i.
And let a sub i be the
storage owned by heap i.
The hoard allocator maintains
the following invariant
for all heaps i.
And the invariant is as follows.
So u sub i is always
going to be greater
than or equal to the min
of a sub i minus 2 times s.
Recall s is the
super block size.
And a sub i over 2.
So how it implements
this is as follows.
When we call free of x, let's
say x is owned by thread i,
then we're going to
put x back into heap i,
and then we're going to check
if the n u storage in heap i,
u sub i is less than the
min of a sub i minus 2 s
and a sub i over 2.
And what this condition
says, if it's true,
it means that your heap
is, at most, half utilized.
Because if it's
smaller than this,
it has to be smaller
than a sub i over 2.
That means there's
twice as much allocated
than used in the local heap i.
And therefore there
must be some super block
that's at least half empty.
And you move that super block,
or one of those super blocks,
to the global heap.
So any questions on how the
allocation and deallocation
works?
So since we're maintaining
this invariant,
it's going to allow us to
approve a bound on the blow up.
And I'll show you that
on the next slide.
But before I go on, are
there any questions?
OK, so let's look at how
we can bound the blow up
of the hoard allocator.
So there is actually
a lemma that we're
going to use and not prove.
The lemma is that the
maximum storage allocated
in the global heap is at most
a maximum storage allocated
in the local heaps.
So we just need to analyze
how much storage is
allocated in the local heaps.
Because the total
amount of storage
is going to be, at
most, twice as much,
since the global heap storage
is dominated by the local heap
storage.
So you can prove this
lemma by case analysis.
And there's the
hoard paper that's
available on learning modules.
And you're free to look
at that if you want
to look at how this is proved.
But here I'm just
going to use this lemma
to prove this theorem, which
says that, let u be the user
footprint for a program.
And let a be the hoard's
allocator footprint.
We have that a as upper
bounded by order u plus s p.
And therefore, a divided
by u, which is a blowup,
is going to be 1 plus
order s p divided by u.
OK, so let's see how
this proof works.
So we're just going to analyze
the storage in the local heaps.
Now recall that we're always
satisfying this invariant here,
where u sub i is greater than
the min of a sub i minus 2 s
and a sub i over 2.
So the first term
says that we can
have 2 s on utilized
storage per heap.
So it's basically giving
two super blocks for free
to each heap.
And they don't have to use it.
They can basically use
it as much as they want.
And therefore, the total
amount of storage contributed
by the first term
is going to be order
s p, because each processor has
up to 2 s unutilized storage.
So that's where the second
term comes from here.
And the second term,
a sub i over 2--
this will give us the
first-term order u.
So this says that
the allocated storage
is at most twice the
use storage for--
and then if you sum up
across all the processors,
then there's a total of order
use storage that's allocated.
Because the allocated
storage can be at most
twice the used storage.
OK, so that's the proof
of the blow up for hoard.
And this is pretty good.
It's 1 plus some
lower order term.
OK, so-- now these are
some other allocators
that people use.
So jemalloc is a
pretty popular one.
Has a few differences
with hoard.
It has a separate global lock
for each different allocation
size.
It allocates the object
with the smallest address
among all the objects
of the requested size.
And it releases empty
pages using m advise,
which we talked about--
I talked about earlier.
And it's pretty popular because
it has good performance,
and it's pretty robust to
different allocation traces.
There's also another one
called SuperMalloc, which
is an up and coming contender.
And it was developed
by Bradley Kuszmaul.
Here are some allocator
speeds for the allocators
that we looked at for
our particular benchmark.
And for this
particular benchmark,
we can see that SuperMalloc
actually does really well.
It's more than three times
faster than jemalloc,
and jemalloc is more than
twice as fast as hoard.
And then the default
allocator, which
uses a global heap is
pretty slow, because it
can't get good speed up.
And all these experiments
are in 32 threads.
I also have the lines of code.
So we see that
SuperMalloc actually
has very few lines
of code compared
to the other allocators.
So it's relatively simple.
OK so, I also have some
slides in Garbage Collection.
But since we're out
of time, I'll just
put these slides online
and you can read them.